The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Well
thanks everyone for coming.
I know that this is kind
of a funky time of day.
So I really appreciate
everyone coming out
to support the students of 2219.
This is the very first time
we ever offered this class.
This is the very first
time I've ever taught,
so I-- it was an awesome
experience for me.
And hopefully it was
a great experience
for all the students.
I am going to pull you guys
up on stage at some point
to talk about what it was like.
Just as a heads up.
So this class was
initially called,
Becoming the Next Bill Nye.
But as many of the
students might tell you,
it's not exactly about
becoming the next Bill Nye.
What it is about is
trying to figure out
how to occupy the space
that's in between education
and entertainment-- a space
that's not very well defined,
a space that doesn't have very
good best practices or best
practices at all.
But the things that are
important in this space
are to create
materials that leave
a door open to the world
of science, technology,
engineering and
math to everyone,
to create materials that foster
a lifelong love of learning,
and to create materials
that promote stem literacy
within the public.
And these are all super
broad sweeping ideas,
but that is sort of
what I think at least
defines the space that's
in between education
and entertainment.
These were the four
class values that we had.
And sorry guys, I know
you've heard this already.
But this is for people who
have never been to the class.
Because we couldn't
really grade things
like is this scene well
lit, because honestly we
were asking them to do so much
within the span of two or three
weeks, these were the values
that were important to us.
Do the materials
that the students
make exhibit a sense of spark?
Is their enthusiasm for the
topic matter very evident?
And this doesn't
mean that they're
talking with their hands,
waving all the time.
It doesn't mean that they're
acting like Hank Green
with like super
hyper personality.
It just means that their
genuine love of the material
is evident.
Is it clear-- "kill
your darlings"
is the phrase I used over
and over again-- but are you
able to really determine
and distill what
your message is very clearly?
Are you thoughtful?
Is every decision that
you go into making--
what your scene looks
like, what your line is,
what your location
is-- is that clear?
And then are you
pushing yourself
outside of your comfort zones?
I think there was
only one student
in this class who'd
ever had experience
with cameras or film.
And I think most of the
students were a little nervous
about being on camera, which
is totally understandable.
It's very, very intimidating
to be in front of the camera.
And I think that over
the course of the two,
three weeks, all these
projects exhibit these values
which I'm very happy about.
So what exactly happened
in the last month?
Well, we basically
took production,
which is all of the
stuff, which I think
is actually structured
the wrong way.
This is really
what production is.
And they had to learn all of
it, in basically two weeks,
because they spent the last
week making their videos.
And this isn't just how
to turn on a camera.
It's how to write an effective
script, how to engage people
with your texts and
your body language,
and the way you're
presenting things.
And then on top
of that, they had
to learn how to use
all the equipment.
And then they had to learn how
to edit sort of on their own,
and learn how to plan
things, and learn
how all of these things
interact with each other.
So what you're about to see
are things that they basically
put together in
like two or three
days, which is kind of
nuts, and with very, very
limited resources.
We had these crappy
little canon camcorders.
So it's pretty impressive when
you think about the constraints
that they had.
One of the things that we
talked about was storyboarding.
So I storyboarded the
class for you guys.
Day one, if you don't
remember, we talked about intro
to the class.
Chris Babel gave a guest
lecture on sort of introduction
to using the camera.
Then on day two, I made
the terrible decision
of not telling
people that we were
going to have 20 sixth
graders come to the classroom.
But luckily Jamie took care
of that before I got there.
And they basically had
to pitch ideas for videos
to 20 sixth graders
from Winthrop.
And then Natalie
Kuldell came and talked
a bit about her experiences
launching BioBuilder, which
is this educational nonprofit.
And then George came in
and did a hosting workshop,
if you guys remember this.
This is only like two
weeks ago, which is crazy.
And then Josh and John
from Planet Nutshell
gave a workshop
on storyboarding.
And then we had our table read.
And then you guys shot
for the first time.
And then you had
another table read.
Wow, did I mess up my pictures?
Sorry.
And then we talked
about post production.
You guys literally learned
the philosophy of editing
in two hours.
And then you went off
to film your episodes.
And then we had one screening.
And then what-- two
more days passed.
One day passed.
And then we're here at today.
So it was a very condensed,
very expedited version
of all that stuff in the
web that I showed earlier.
And so speaking of storyboards,
we are at our first project.
This was Yuliya's
first storyboard.
And yes, I combed
through the Tumblr,
and I'm pulling up all the
embarrassing first drafts
of everything that
people posted.
Yuliya's first
storyboard-- and I'm
bummed because the text is super
small and you can't see it--
but it's her first
version of her script.
And it's basically
her first attempt
at planning what her
video was going to be.
And the intro was what do a
snowflake and cellphone have
in common.
And her plan was to
go out by the Charles,
maybe while it was snowing.
And then she's going to have
all these things about fractals,
and how fractals are everywhere.
Fractals are crazy.
They're in broccoli.
Oh my gosh, so many fractals!
And then she starts
talking about fractals.
Yuliya, do you mind
coming on up here?
Pin this to yourself.
What was the process
like-- hang on,
I'm going to give
this to you too--
what was the process like
going from this storyboard
to the video that
we're about to see?
YULIYA: Well I mostly
changed the script
since this storyboard.
But this kind of helped
me think through what
are some possible locations
I'm going to film at,
what animations I can use.
So this was very
important for me
to kind of imagine
what was happening,
but not just in my script, but
also how it would look on film.
And then I noticed
that there were
some issues with the
storyboard, and then
changed the script afterwards.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And
how-- your script
probably changed the most.
Well, there were some drastic
changes that happened.
But from your very
first idea from day one,
your thought what to do
something about math,
but how math wasn't real.
It was like this very
philosophical idea.
And it was awesome.
But we had no idea how she
would tell it in five minutes.
So how did it evolve
over the course
or what were some
of the challenges
that you had revising it?
YULIYA: So I
started with talking
about Godel's incompleteness
theorem, which asks
the question of is math real?
And then I pitched that
idea to sixth graders.
And I came back, and
I was really shocked
that I ever thought that I could
explain that to sixth graders.
So then I have to think,
well what else can I
tell about math?
And I like theoretical
math, so all
of the concepts
that I line in math
are abstract, and don't really
have a concrete application.
So I start freaking out.
And then eventually I
came up with this idea
of fractals which
were doodles, and they
were present everywhere nature.
So it could be made relatable.
It could be made concrete,
even though it was this very
abstract math concept.
So that was the third
script that I wrote.
That was about fractals
and chaos theory.
Then I wrote another one, which
didn't talk about chaos theory,
because that was also complex.
So the issue for me was
coming up with a topic
that I could enjoy
talking about,
but also sixth graders
would enjoy hearing about.
And in the process
I also realized
that I need more
help than I thought,
and more practice
than I thought.
So it was a very
humbling experience,
especially the table reads.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And how do you
feel about your final video?
Again, what they're working
with are these small cameras.
Most of them had never touched
a camera really before.
None of them had
used editing software
except for maybe one or two.
So how do you feel
about the final product
that we're about to see?
YULIYA: Well, I'm not very happy
with the quality of the video.
And I think part of it is I had
to transfer between computers,
and work with software.
There are definitely
some scenes I
would re-film if I had
more time to get better
lighting and better sound.
And it's only three and
a half minutes long.
So I could definitely
add more math to it.
But I think that yesterday
when I uploaded it,
I was pretty happy with what
I got in the time that I had.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Awesome.
OK, well we'll watch your video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What do snowflakes and
cell phones have in common?
The answer is never ending
patterns called fractals.
To explain, let me start
by drawing a snowflake.
First, I draw an
equilateral triangle,
divide each side
into three parts.
I draw another equilateral
triangle on top of each one.
Then take out the middle
and repeat the process,
this time with one,
two, three, four,
times three, which is 12 sides.
Eventually, the shape will start
looking something like this.
In mathematics, this is
called a cox snowflake.
If I repeated my
process again and again,
I would see this same
pattern anywhere I looked.
This is a cox snowflake, this
time drawn on your computer.
Such neverending patterns
that are under any scale,
on any level of zoom,
look roughly the same,
are called fractals.
Computer scientists can
program these patterns
by repeating an often
simple mathematical process
over and over.
And in 1990s, a
regular astronomer,
by the name of Nathan
Cohen, used fractals
to revolutionize
wireless communications.
At the time, Cohen was having
troubles with his landlord.
The man wouldn't let him
put an antenna on his roof.
So Cohen designed a more
compact, fractal radio antenna
instead.
The landlord didn't notice it.
And it worked better
than the ones before.
Working further, Cohen
designed a new antenna,
this time using a fractal
called the menger sponge.
The menger sponge
is not the name
of the sponge you'd be
scrubbing your back with.
But you can still
think of it like that.
Imagine with water and soap
getting through the sponge's
holes, except the water is Wi-Fi
and soap is safe Bluetooth.
The fractal's
infinite sponginess
allows it to receive many
different frequencies
simultaneously.
Before Cohen's
invention, antennas
had to be cut for one frequency.
And that was the only
frequency they could offer.
Alcon sponge, your
cellphone would
have to look something
like a hedgehog
to receive multiple
signals, including
the one your friends
use when they call.
Cohen later proved that
only fractal shapes
could work in such a wide
range of frequencies.
Today millions of
wireless devices,
such as laptops and
barcode scanners,
use Cohen's fractal antenna.
Cohen's genius
invention, however,
was not the first application
of fractals in the world.
Nature has been doing it
the whole time, and not
just with snowflakes.
Natural selection gave us
the most efficient systems
of organisms, all
in the fractal form.
The spiral fractal,
for example, is
present in sea shells,
broccoli and hurricanes.
The fractal tree is
relatively easy to program,
and can be used to study
river systems, blood vessels
and lightning holes.
So many natural systems,
previously thought off
limits to
mathematicians, can now
be understood in
terms of fractals.
Mathematics allows us to
learn each of those practices,
and then apply them to
solve real-world problems.
Much like Cohen's
antenna, revolutionized
telecommunications, on
the fractal research,
is changing medicine,
weather prediction and art,
here at MIT and
everywhere in the world.
Look around you.
What beautiful
patterns do you see?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: I
forgot to mention--
so obviously, if a
student's on screen hosting,
they are not filming
their own project.
So what we did was paired
people up into groups,
and they filmed each other.
So that piece was filmed
by Kenneth and PJ,
and they all worked together to
help each other out and direct
each other, and it was awesome.
Next up, we have PJ.
Now PJ, for you--
you can come on up.
I took your second pitch
from the Tumblr posts--
PJ: All right.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
--where you had come up
with the idea of
talking about ships.
His first-- yes?
Oh, thank you, sorry.
You had come up with
the idea of talking
about the science
behind poached eggs?
PJ: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And--
PJ: Yeah, you shouldn't
show that one.
ELIZABETH CHOE: How did--
PJ: I don't even know
how to poach an egg, so--
ELIZABETH CHOE:
How did that turn
from the science of
poached eggs to what
ended up being a video about
how ships basically don't sink?
PJ: Well, honestly I was trying
to look for something easy.
And poaching eggs isn't
actually that easy.
So I wanted to
learn how to do it.
And I thought it'd
be some where I'd
be able to present on something,
and also learn something myself
but-- also I could just do
it in my kitchen at home.
So it seemed very accessible.
But yeah, I decided to ditch
that because it's a lot harder
than people-- or I think people
know it's hard to poach an egg
so--
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK, so
let's watch your pitch
and then we can talk
about it, and how
it changed to your final video.
Oh, woops.
Can everyone see that OK?
Can I leave the back light on?
PJ: Let us assume for a second
that this cardboard box I
hold in front of you is a ship.
Let's say it's a box barge.
It kind of looks like a barge.
Now what I've done for you
is drawn the water line.
And what that is is that is the
level at which the barge would
float on top of
the water, assuming
that it's going to float.
Now if I take these
scissors, and create damage
to the bow section
of this barge,
what do you think would happen?
You'd probably be
right in saying
that water is going to
go through this hole
that I created, fill
up in the barge,
and that the barge
is going to sink.
Now let's take that same
scenario and do it again.
So you want to damage this
bow portion right here.
Now what do you
think would happen?
You'd probably say
that well, you just did
that so it's going to sink.
Water's going to
climb in that hole,
and it's going to sink the ship.
But you'd be wrong.
What I did is I took these
cardboard pieces right here,
and subdivided the vessel.
And what that means is
that when water comes in
through this hole,
it's just going
to fill up this compartment.
Now what that's
going to do, it's
going to cause a trim
condition in the barge,
but it's not going sink.
And people on
board are not going
to be injured as a result
of the vessel sinking.
Now I show you this
example as a segway
into what naval architects do.
One of the most important
features of designing a ship
is making sure it's not going
to sink, as easy as it sounds.
And the way that we do that
it through subdivision.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So I showed
that because basically
the difference between this
and the video that you're
about to see in terms of content
isn't super, super different.
The science, the basic
science behind it
isn't incredibly different.
So what happened
between you making this
to you making your final video?
PJ: Well I kind of
knew the resources
that I had at MIT to do a pretty
decent job trying to show it.
So that was tough
trying to organize
that, like getting
the labs I had
to go to because I don't
actually work in these labs.
So it's-- it was tough
to schedule that.
But I knew it would be possible.
So I just tried to do it,
and had lot of fun int
he process so--
ELIZABETH CHOE: I don't
think that this is actually
a bad video at all.
I think that you'll
go on YouTube,
and you'll find a ton of
videos just like this one where
it's someone that just set
up their camera back at home,
and they're talking a little
bit about a physics concept.
Which one do you like
better-- this one or the one
that you made for the project?
PJ: I liked the
first one better.
No, the second one's definitely
a little bit more in depth,
and kind of goes into the
science a little bit more so--
ELIZABETH CHOE: What was the
hardest part about getting
to this final video?
PJ: I'd say-- I think it was
probably organizing all of it
because just the different
shots that had to take
and everything-- it
was pretty tough.
But it was good having
Kenneth and Yuliya.
They definitely helped to--
I think my storyboard was
kind of all over the place.
But they were like, no, you
should do it from this angle
and you should try
it from this angle.
So I got a lot good
stuff that I could edit.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Yeah,
and you actually
said that it was easier
for you to be on camera
when you were
around other people
than when you were by yourself.
PJ: Yeah.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Well, let's have
a look at your final project.
PJ: You want me to sit down?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INAUDIBLE]
-When we take complex
things, and break them
into smaller pieces, we find
out that we know a lot more
about things than we think.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now let's this box
Orca One, and create
damage below the waterline
which I've indicated right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now let's take Orca One on the
water and see what happens.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Orca One sank due to the
weight of the added water.
What if the Orca One contained
cargo or oil or even people?
Now let's take Orca Two,
and do the same thing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BELL RINGING]
So we can see that
Orca Two did not sink,
although it is sitting at
an angle towards the bow.
So why didn't Orca Two sink?
As easy as it sounds,
this simple demonstration
is essential to the design
of huge, complex ships--
ships that are responsible
for carrying about 90%
of all our stuff.
If [INAUDIBLE], how do
we [INAUDIBLE] ships
carrying our stuff to make
into ports safely and not sink?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
He we have Orca One and
Orca Two from before.
Although Orca One
and Orca Two don't
engage in international
trade, they
behave just as 1,000 foot
container ship would.
Now let's take a
look into Orca One.
We can see that
there's nothing in it.
It's just a box.
But if you look at
Orca Two, we can
see that it's subdivided into
these watertight compartments
by these tranverse
watertight bulkheads.
Now what that
means is that if we
were to damage a
ship right here,
water would only flow
into this compartment.
It would not go into this
one, this one or this one.
That would cause the ship to be
angled or trimmed in the water,
but it would not cause the
ship to sink completely.
We refer to Orca Two
as being subdivided.
And we can see subdivision in
many of these ships' plans.
It is unclear when
subdivision first
started being used in ships,
but accounts of fifth century
Chinese trade ships
indicated that water
would be able to enter the
vessel without sinking.
So let's find out
why this happens.
Let's imagine a barge divided
into ten equal compartments.
One of them springs
a leak from damage.
Since the ship is subdivided,
only the first compartment
floats and the
ship remains afloat
protecting both its
people and cargo.
Although the added water causes
the ship to trim, is still
has enough buoyancy to
return to port for repairs.
Ships still sink, though.
It's both expensive
and impractical
to try to design
an unsinkable ship,
especially when these
ships will never
see that amount of damage.
That's why, as
naval architects, we
use computer programs to
help us out with subdivision.
Computers make it easy
to see certain damage
cases in practically no time.
With different software, we
can damage certain compartments
and see how the
ship responds to it.
This gives the naval
architect a good idea
of what parts to improve
on the ship, if any.
So even though ships seem
like these intricate, complex
things, they're really
just based on principles
that we all already know.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: All
right, so [INAUDIBLE],
I don't know if you saw me
mess up, but you're up next.
I accidentally fast forwarded
through all the slides.
So I'm also going to
show-- that's this just
the sound that's there.
You can't see?
Shouldn't have done that.
Here we go.
So Andrea, you can come on up.
So I'm going to show the
second pitch that you did.
I guess my question for you is,
you knew pretty early on where
you were going to write about.
I think your topic stayed
pretty much the same,
but the way that
you were saying it
changed a lot over the
course of the class.
So, I guess, what was the
most important thing that you
learned in the past few weeks?
ANDREA: Oh gosh, the
most important thing.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Or maybe
the most practical thing.
Here you go, sorry.
ANDREA: OK, two things--
persistence and iteration.
And the persistence was
by far the harder thing
to really do, because
I'd experience
a block at something.
My first one was that I was too
much in, like, businesswoman
presenting information mode,
and it wasn't very authentic.
And I didn't think--
I was like, I'm not
trying to sell orthodontics
to the sixth graders.
That's kind of ridiculous.
ELIZABETH CHOE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREA: I'm trying to
teach them about science.
So it was just a
series of blocks
that I really just had to
work through, much like life.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
What type of advice
would you give anyone who's
going to give a talk, who's
going to make a video?
Just anyone who's
trying to communicate
their technical ideas
to lay audience.
Because you come from a
very interesting background.
So, Andrea is a
Sloan fellow, so she
has a sense of presentation and
communication minus the video.
So, I guess drawing on
all these experiences,
what type of advice
would you give to folks?
ANDREA: Well, I think
the first time you ever
try to present
information, you think
you're going to get through
a lot more information
than you actually will, and
that was the first thing
that I learned when I taught.
I went with a lesson
plan of like 20 things,
and I only got through,
like, maybe four.
So I think that that's
your first lesson
is, keep it simple initially.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
Awesome, do you-- well,
let's watch your pitch first.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-My name's Andrea [INAUDIBLE],
and I'm a Sloan fellow,
as I mentioned earlier.
And my pitch idea
is actually having
to do with something
that I actually
know something a
little bit about,
that many middle schoolers
also struggle with.
And that is having braces.
I just recently
got my braces off,
and I also worked for
an orthodontics company
before I came here to MIT.
So it's something that's both
near and dear to my heart,
and also I think I've seen a
lot of high schoolers and middle
schoolers struggle with
this whole process.
I know I didn't know
a whole lot about it.
So basically, that
would be my pitch.
To teach kids about what's
happening with their teeth
as they're having braces on.
How the teeth move, how
osteoblasts and osteoclasts
work, and to deposit and
dissolve some of their bone,
which is actually one of the
reasons why it hurts so much.
And also why your mouth
gets dry-- all those kinds
of scientific
aspects of something
that these kids really
deal with on a daily basis
during a very awkward
time of their life.
So that's my main pitch.
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: So
before we see your video,
what's one thing that
you're really proud of,
and one thing that you
want to change if you had
more time or more resources?
ANDREA: OK, that's a
really hard question.
I'd change the whole thing.
But the one thing
that I liked about it
is that I tried to
keep my sense of humor
in the video, and the one thing
that I wish I could change
is learning more about
lighting and editing,
and just more of the
technical details.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Awesome.
Well, let's go
ahead and watch it.
ANDREA: Do you want
me to stay up here?
ELIZABETH CHOE:
You can move down.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Eating is one of the great
pleasures and necessities
of life, and to enjoy everything
from energy bars to apples,
we rely on one
part of our bodies
to do an important
job, our teeth.
Teeth are the hardest
substances in our bodies.
They are harder than
our bones, and they're
even harder than iron or steel.
So, why doesn't our
jaw just crumble
under all of those forces?
Between your tooth
and your jawbone,
there's a specialized
piece of tissue
called the periodontal
ligament, or PDL for short.
The PDL can easily
absorb the normal forces
that a tooth experiences when we
chew, say, an apple, cushioning
or protecting our
jawbone from our teeth.
Teeth sound like they're
already perfectly designed,
but sometimes we really
need to force them
in a certain direction,
like with braces.
As the braces slowly
force the teeth to move,
the PDL is squeezed
in one direction
and stretched in the other.
To make room, the
mechanoreceptors
in the PDL trigger
cells called osteoclasts
that actually come in
and dissolve part of jaw
to make extra room.
The mechanoreceptors
also trigger another kind
of cell called and osteoblast,
which comes in and builds up
part of the jaw bone.
This allows the PDL to get back
into its regular, cushioning
shape, thus, holding the
tooth securely in position.
So if braces use osteoblasts
to physically reposition teeth
for cosmetic reasons,
what if wanted
to use them to replace
things in our bodies?
Dental implants
replace teeth that
are damaged or missing to
restore chewing function.
Your jaw isn't the
only place where
these osteoblasts
and osteoclasts are
altering your bone structure.
In fact, this bony
remodeling process
is happening throughout
your entire body.
And these implants aren't
just limited to teeth.
Doctors can replace knees,
hips, even spinal discs,
and MIT engineers are using
the properties of osteoblasts
and osteoclasts that are
already in our bodies
to create a chemical
coding for these implants.
Just like in a
mouth with braces,
this coding helps
create natural bone
to help lock the
implant into place.
Right now, these
implants are designed
to have the exact same
functionality as the parts
that they're replacing.
But scientists are already
developing implants
to improve the performance
of our bodies and brains.
So at that point, will we
be more machine than human?
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right,
so Nathan, why don't you
come on up.
Every day, the students had
to write a daily reflection
on our class blog,
which is open to anyone.
Any one of you guys can
go see it, if you want.
And this is in addition to
doing all the assignments
that they had to do.
But they would just
talk about what
the day was like, what they
learned, what was challenging--
just any thoughts.
And they could either post
pictures, or write things,
or make video blogs.
And Nathan, by far, had the
most entertaining blogs.
And I'm just going to show you
it, and then we talk about it.
NATHAN: All right,
second day down.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh wait,
Nathan, can you scoot over?
Whoops.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-All right, second day down.
No, third-- third day--
so, third day-- all right,
so, third day reflection.
A lot happening.
So much that's
good, actually, so I
guess I'll start with
the first thing that pops
into mind, which is shooting.
I've just got done finally
finishing my trailer pitch
thing.
And one thing I guess you always
know, but you don't appreciate,
is how many tries at
shooting something
it takes to get something
you're satisfied with.
Because, oh my
gosh, I don't still
really like what
I've come out with,
but I spent a good
hour and a half
repeating the same thing
over and over again,
and I don't know.
I am OK with what
came of it, because I
know it's still
very, very rough,
and that's the point of it.
So--
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: So that's
part of his day three blog.
So the reason why I said sort
of becoming the next Bill Nye
is that what I
didn't want to end up
happening was people
thinking that this class was
about molding them into
some science celebrity that
was becoming a next Bill Nye, or
becoming the next Neil deGrasse
Tyson, or becoming
the Hank Green,
because what I think is so
awesome about what is here
in the student body, and what
everyone in this class brought,
was their own individual
personalities.
And I would have
hated it if Nathan
was trying to be Bill
Nye, because he's
so much better as Nathan.
And that's why his
blogs are so great.
So Nathan, what
was-- I know that you
had said that it was
hard to be on camera,
and it was hard
to do production,
but your blogs
are so effortless,
and your video blogs--
they're very you.
So what was so hard
about doing something
when you had a line to say?
You can just clip it to
yourself if you want.
NATHAN: I think we
made it so hard was,
if I'm just doing a
blog sort of thing,
I think of it in a way of, like,
I'm just talking to someone.
But when I'm trying
to go with the script
it becomes a lot more
formal in my mind,
and I just get nervous.
ELIZABETH CHOE: How do feel
about how the video that we're
about to watch turned out?
How do you feel
about your hosting?
What was it like shooting that?
NATHAN: I think there's
still a lot that I think
could be better about
it, but if I look back
at the very first pitch video
I did, and the second one,
and even the rough cut,
it's definitely improved.
So, I'll take what I can.
ELIZABETH CHOE:
What are you most
proud of in your final project?
NATHAN: Probably
that, I remember
when we did the [INAUDIBLE], the
first table reads as scripts,
mine was, one, a lot
different from what it is
now, but also very, very long.
And now, it took like about
a little over five minutes
to read through just
on the table, which
is, in theory, faster than
it would be in a video.
And the whole kill your
darlings thing happened,
and I ended up with about two
and a half minute long video.
So I think that's
what I like most.
ELIZABETH CHOE: OK, well,
let's see what you got.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Why does a fridge
start to smell,
and where does that icky
black liquid come from?
Wouldn't it just be easier
if things didn't rot?
If things lasted forever?
Well maybe, but probably not.
The average American household
wasts about 25% of its food,
and lot of restaurants
are even worse.
So if we didn't
have decomposition,
what would happen to all
of the food we throw away?
Food and microbes usually get
settled by bacteria, protists,
and fungi that allow
nutrients in the food
to return to the soil and,
eventually, other living
things.
These decomposers also
break down other dead stuff,
like trees.
In fact, they're pretty much the
only thing that can eat wood.
So even if in a
world without rot,
where you don't have to worry
about your house getting eaten
by termites, who align
protists in their stomachs,
pretty soon forests
and landfills
would be flooded with
a lot of dead stuff.
How do we avoid this problem?
Well, basically in your
fridge, on the forest floor,
in the dumpster,
almost anywhere there
are fungi, bacteria, and
protists that live entirely
by eating dead stuff.
These dead things can
be more or less divided
into three categories.
Carbohydrates-- sugar
and starches-- lipids--
think fats-- and
proteins like meats.
All of these are
chemically different,
so they each get broken
down by different enzymes
in different ways before
being absorbed by decomposers.
For example, proteases
break down proteins
into amino acids, the
cells building blocks.
Lipids rely on lipases,
and carbohydrates on things
like amylase and cellulases.
So how does a perfectly
nice broccoli floret
start giving off this
foul black liquid?
Fruits and vegetables are
almost entirely made of water,
so on the most
basic level you can
see the cells are like extremely
complex water balloons.
The exterior of the
cell wall is made
of cellulose, a complex
carbohydrate that
gets broken down by enzymes that
the smaller cell can get energy
from.
The bacteria or fungi
uses cellulase to eat
the exterior of the cell.
It's like if I were
to pop the balloon.
That's the muck you
see in your fridge.
What about that stink?
For fruits and vegetables,
a lot of times the smell
happens after the icky
black liquid forms.
Other bacterial that
weren't involved
in the initial
colonization move in,
and start to stink
everything up.
Meat gets smelly when lipases
break down fat in the meat
into glycerol and fatty
acids, two energy sources,
and fatty acids
are kind of gross.
And so while your food rotting
may smell absolutely terrible,
because of it the
environment's able to recycle
crucial nutrients it needs.
And, well, that's
why we have all this.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right,
so David, you can come on up.
As I was saying, the students
all have to post daily blogs,
and after the first
day I was really
curious to read what everyone
thought about the class, how
they were feeling,
and David's was
one of the first ones I read.
I don't know if you
can see it, but it
says, "Today was the first
day in the class of MIT 219.
I felt pretty much
overwhelmed with the amount
of course work required
from the get go,
but also pleasantly surprised
by the amount of enthusiasm
from students and teachers
alike in the course.
This will be a day
of many firsts, then.
First time making
a blog, first time
using Tumblr, first
time making a video
describing something myself.
Previously, we had
done in a group setting
and it wasn't such
a good experience."
So I read that and I was like,
oh no, I totally miss-gauged
everyone's starting level.
I gave too much to do.
This is going to be
an interesting month.
How do you feel now that you
not only have mastered Tumblr,
but you're uploading
videos, you're
making videos on
your own-- was it
as bad of an experience
as the first one?
DAVID: Actually, I felt
it was much better.
Really, a lot much
better, and I'm
very grateful for all the
help that we've been getting
from all the teaching staff.
And at first I was really--
because the first three times
that we made video I was quite
demoralized, because the video
came out quite badly.
And then when I
watched it I was, like,
cringing at the videos.
So because of-- but I
feel it is because when
we did the video
shoot most of the time
I was doing it by myself, so
I couldn't have another person
to shoot it against, to let a
person tell me what is good,
what it bad about a video.
However, in this
class, every day
we have opinions given to us
as to what we can improve,
what we can take out, what
is better, what to cut.
And so I think
through this process
we improve our videos much
more than we could have alone.
ELIZABETH CHOE: And
I forgot to mention,
so the last three videos
that I'm going to show
are from SUTD students.
So we got to host a few students
who are from the Singapore
University of
Technology and Design,
and it was super
interesting having
all of your guys' perspectives.
I was thinking before
the class started, like,
how's this going to work?
Culturally, are people
going to have the same sort
of digital media literacy?
And I feel like you
guys were like, oh
yeah, we've seen Slideshow,
we've seen Veritasium.
We already know about
these YouTube channels.
So I was like, OK, this is
going to be totally fine.
But David, you
guys are going back
to Singapore tomorrow morning.
Do you think that you will
take any of the things
that we did in class?
Either maybe making more
videos, on in your talks,
or what types of things
were most useful to you?
DAVID: I don't think that I'll
be making more videos because I
think it's really quite hard.
And to do it, really
you need a lot of people
to do it with you.
But one thing I
will take back is
how to give effective feedback.
Because I actually feel
that in this class,
many times the feedback
was very effective,
and it came across
very pleasantly.
So I'm very thankful for that.
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right, well
let's see your final project.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-If I went out front right
now, dressed like this,
you'd probably call
me nuts, right?
Because it's so
cold outside that
I'd probably die of hypothermia.
However, in 2009,
Wim Hof managed
to run a full marathon in -20
degrees Celsius wearing nothing
but shorts.
While most people
would probably die,
Wim Hof has managed to survive.
So, what makes Wim Hof able
to survive while others can't?
The research team [INAUDIBLE]
icy bath for almost two hours.
Well, most people who
had their core body temp
to below 35 degrees
causing hypothermia
to kick in, Wim Hof's
body temperature dropped
to nearly 37.4 degrees
Celsius, staying slightly warm.
And the funny thing is that
the researchers couldn't
find exactly what had happened.
Maybe it's a genetic adaptation.
In a separate
study, studies have
found that individuals
with [INAUDIBLE] ancestry
have mitochondria
that can produce
more heat and lactic energy.
Mitochondria is
like a mini furnace
that burns the sugars from food
we eat into chemical and heat
energy.
Individuals like get better
able to survive the cold.
However, scientists haven't
fully studied Wim Hof's genome,
so we don't really know.
Wim Hof practices g-tummo
as a form of meditation
and [INAUDIBLE] which allows
him to double his metabolism.
Regardless of condition
before, Wim Hof
can produce enough heat
through his mitochondria
with specific breathing
and muscle contractions.
They can produce enough
heat to keep his body warm.
Well, you might believe
that this is not scientific.
However, studies
at NUS have shown
that diversity increase the core
temp of the individual using
g-tummo, and the inner
prior medication experience.
Now, why could this be so?
Increases in alpha and
beta waves are notices,
and many have theorized that
this has enabled the body
to effectively heat the center
as far as the and the knees.
We do not fully understand
Wim Hof's methods,
and while some have tried
following his footsteps,
it would be unwise
to do the same.
And Wim Hof, you
don't hear him saying
he can control all
parts of his body.
Now, if this were true,
and scientifically backed,
who knows what doors could open?
While science has already
audited and I myself
don't practice
Wim Hof's methods,
maybe I better be
off only one jacket.
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: Oh wait, sorry,
did I cut it off too early?
Actually, I'll show
your pitch first,
then we can talk about it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Everyone has pretty much seen
a science fiction movie in this
day in age, and I'm pretty sure
everyone has seen at least one
that involves time travelling.
Maybe it's Star Trek,
Interstellar, or more recently,
Predestination.
And it's such a widely
[INAUDIBLE] topic in science
fiction, the whole genre
of time travelling.
But many times,
Hollywood films always
have these little,
little loopholes
in their storyline
and their plot lines,
and they often use theories and
science to explain themselves,
which are just like
got from machine
solutions-- totally
not efficient.
However, scientists have
actually put forward three main
theories when it comes
to time travelling.
First theory-- the
fixed timeline theory.
Say, for example, you're
trying to prevent World War II,
and you travel back in time
after inventing a time machine.
And after killing the baby
that was supposed to be Hitler,
you put-- I don't know, some
other baby from an orphanage,
and put it in the same cot.
However, when you travel
back in the future,
you realize that the baby
that you had replaced it with
was the one that turn
out to be Hitler,
and there is no changing
of the past, effectively,
or the future, or the present.
It's all in a fixed timeline.
And this particular motions
are actually often seen
in movies such as Harry Potter.
It was seen in
Interstellar as well.
It was also seen
in Predestination.
It's a good film.
You have to catch it.
The second theory is
the multiverse theory,
which states that every
time you go back in time
and you alter the
history-- for example,
you step on a butterfly and that
butterfly could actually maybe
be the prevention
of, I don't know,
a hurricane that sweeps
through Orlando right
now-- you spawn a new
set of events which
happens in a separate universe.
Which, in other words means
that you have actually
got infinite number
of universes after you
have all these
different decisions
and different chain
of events occurring
And this particular
timeline concept
has legitimately explored
many times as well.
It's been featured in the
recent regular Star Trek movies.
It's also been featured
in recent Fringe series,
which kind of I hate because
JJ Abrams right now remind me
of something.
And yeah, this multiverse
series is actually quite popular
because it's the easiest
for producers to just show
the solution, and
then they'll say,
oh, we actually spawned
off a new timeline.
So that's when you
get sloppy and lazy.
The third theory you
have is what we call
the dynamic timeline theory.
It's also the theory which
induces all the paradoxes.
Which, you often hear
about these paradoxes,
such as the grandfather paradox,
where you go back in time
and you kill the
grandfather, and because you
kill the grandfather,
you won't exist.
And because you won't exist
you can't go back in time
and save the
grandfather, and that's
where the whole
paradox comes in.
Who kills who?
God knows.
The third theory we have is
called the dynamic timeline
theory, which is also where
all your grandfather paradoxes
come in.
Let's say your grandfather is
a really, really evil man--
Hitler-- and you have to go
back in time to kill him.
And you go back,
you do the deed,
and then you realize that,
oh no, after I kill him
I can't exist.
And because you can't exist,
you can't go back in time
to kill him.
And because of
that, he comes back.
And then after you
have to come back,
and you have to go back
in time again [INAUDIBLE].
That's where the paradox starts.
It's an infinite circle
of never ending events,
and that's how the
grandfather paradox came
about to be in the first place.
And I think you may have seen
it in Back to the Future.
And I can't really think of
any other film right now.
So, this is a brief
history of time travel
and the three theories
associated with it,
as well as a quick touch
on the grandfather paradox.
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: All right,
come on up, Kenneth.
So of the four values-- I
don't know if you all remember,
but there's spark,
there's clarity,
there is thoughtfulness, and
there's challenge, right?
Kenneth obviously is not
lacking in spark whatsoever,
which is awesome.
As soon as you see this
video-- and this was
the very first thing
you did-- and you have
some video experience, right?
KENNETH: Yeah, I have.
And if I had known
this would be shown I
would have put on more clothes.
Yeah, I have had some.
ELIZABETH CHOE: So the
video technique was there,
and the enthusiasm
for the subject matter
was definitely there.
So how did you go from this
pitch, which is basically
it's own video-- it's kind
of like a mini SciShow video,
basically, on all the
theories of time travel.
How did you go from this to
the video we're about to see?
KENNETH: So this was talking
about the three main theories
of time travel, and
this happened right
before we saw the sixth graders.
And when I started talking
to the six graders,
I realized that
most of them haven't
seen Interstellar or all of
these new Star Trek movies.
Funnily enough, they have
seen Back to the Future.
So yeah, I realized
what really intrigued
them about time travel wasn't
all these paradoxes, or all
these theories, or the timeline.
They were more interested in
how is it possible-- is it
even possible, and
other questions.
So it wasn't-- they were
interested in time travel,
just not my scope that
I initially planned.
So I decided to
change it up a bit.
Maybe talk more about the
science of time travel
itself, which is where
I went to at the end.
ELIZABETH CHOE: I mean,
something to emphasize too-- we
talked about on the first
day that this space is
so hard to work in
because what is good
is not defined by anyone.
So just because
the sixth graders
wanted you to talk about the
exact science of time travel,
and we encourage you to do
that, that doesn't necessarily
mean that this video is bad,
or that people wouldn't really
be into a video about the
science behind Interstellar.
That's not true at all.
So part of the challenge
of working in this space
is knowing who to sacrifice--
what audience to sacrifice when
you decide to make your video.
What were some of the
new or unexpected things
that you had learned that you
didn't know about production?
KENNETH: Sound is important.
Sound is really,
really important.
Yeah, if I had more time I would
re-shoot some of the scenes
because the sound
was just so bad.
Other things-- I realize
my writing and my speaking
is really, really,
very different.
My initial script when
we first wrote it out,
I think it was about seven--
six to seven minutes long.
My final cut is short
of four minutes.
So I think while
filming it's really
a big difference to
how we bring things--
how I brought things across.
It feels a lot more
natural to speak just ad
lib to the camera.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Awesome.
Any final thoughts
before we show yours?
KENNETH: Be forgiving.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Thanks, Kenneth.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Imagine holding a party
and then sending out
invitations after the party.
Wait a minute, that
doesn't make any sense.
Are my friends going to
be able to time travel
back just to attend my party?
In 2009, Steven Hawking actually
conducted such an experiment
to disprove time travel.
But what exactly is time
travel, and how does it work?
It actually has a
lot to do with speed.
A lot of what we know about
time traveling actually
comes from Einstein's theory of
special and general relativity.
We are actually time
travelling right now,
but not in the manner that
sci-fi films have depicted it.
We are, in fact, time travelling
at a pace of one hour per hour.
In other words, every hour I
experience, the world around me
experiences a
singular hour, too.
Now, it may sound simple and
trivial, but stay with me.
This is where it
gets interesting.
Now, a [INAUDIBLE] of Einstein's
theory of special relativity
is actually a phenomenon
known as time dilation.
Effectively, this means that
the faster you travel the slower
time passes around you.
It potentially
means that I could
travel at maybe more
than one hour per hour.
This phenomenon, however, is
only noticeable at really,
really high speeds-- speeds
near the speed of light.
This rocket here,
not even close.
Say I do have a
spaceship now that
travels at 90% the
speed of light,
and I have a pair
of newborn twins.
I bring one of them with me
on this journey for 10 years.
When I return, one of them
will have turned 23 years old,
while the one will me will
have only tuned 10 years old.
While we have experienced
10 years on the spaceship,
23 years have actually
passed on earth.
This amount of time actually
increases exponentially
as we get closer to
the speed of light.
So, we could have potentially
travelled forward in time,
but what about
backwards in time?
That's a loaded issue.
Now, remember our
previous draft.
The time that it
took [INAUDIBLE]
to the speed of light.
Some scientists think
maybe the secret to time
travel lies on the
other side of the line.
In other words, we may
have to travel faster
than the speed of light just to
be able to travel back in time.
Now, when you do travel at
speeds near the speed of light,
something called relativistic
mass comes into play.
In other words, as your speed
goes up your mass increases.
As your masses increases,
you require more energy
to move the same object.
This might mean that we need
an infinite amount of energy
just to move [INAUDIBLE]
beyond the speed of light.
However, the more energy you put
into an object, the more likely
you are to increase
its mass rather than
to increase its speed.
Therefore, to gather
[INAUDIBLE] quite impossible
at this point in time.
So, why are we still so
obsessed with time travel?
Time travel does come with
it's own set of problems.
Take, for example,
my party before.
If I were to send out my
invitations after the party,
my friends would have come
back in time to attend.
And if they did come
back in time to attend,
I wouldn't have to have
sent out my invitations.
And if I didn't send
out my invitations
they wouldn't be at my party.
Doesn't make any sense at all
that they are both at my party
and not at my party.
This is what we call
the grandfather paradox.
It's one of three
time travel theories
that we currently have.
Now, so it seems that we may
not be able to time travel
yet, based on what
physics tells us at least.
For now, if you are
planning a party,
be sure to send out
the invites first.
Your friends can't
time travel yet.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: We
have one more video.
Joshua, I'm going to
show your day three blog.
This was the day after that
we had our hosting and script
writing workshop.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I thought what really
stood out for me
was the one of looking at
a member of your audience
like your family member or a
professor behind the camera,
so it's not just a camera.
So yeah, but the funny thing
is, speaking of this tip,
I kind of forgot it and I've
been looking at the camera
thinking of the camera.
So it's a bit ironic.
I guess many if these things
require a lot of practice,
and that's kind of like
why you do, and get out
of the zone of thinking
I'm in front of a camera.
Usually, every time you press a
camera there's this red button.
Sometimes I think maybe
if that red button
was eliminated that a lot of
things would be different.
Yeah, so I guess
one of my questions
I would like to ask as well
is, what kind of face-- what
would be a perfect
member of the audience
that I would like to put there?
I mean, if I put someone
who is very respectable,
like my professor, then I
guess that the whole tonality
in my voice, the whole
choice of my vocabulary
would try to be more serious.
By the same time, I
guess if I put someone
like a two-year-old
in my imagination
in front of the camera,
I'll probably not
talk in the same tonality.
So I guess, what would
an appropriate member
of the audience be in front
of the camera, or some of--
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE: So that's
a very hard question.
You can come on up.
And the thing that's
hard when you're hosting
is that there's a
difference between talking
to and for your audience,
which is a point that George
brought up during the workshop.
But being able to
actually implement
that, as you mentioned,
it's really hard.
So what did you think of
when you were hosting?
Because I think that the
way you talk in this blog
is totally appropriate for sixth
grader, for your professor.
But being able to distill like
who you are as an individual,
and having the
self-awareness to process,
like, this is how I really--
this is who I am at my core.
That's actually a
really hard thing to do.
So how are you able to
do in your final video?
JOSHUA: I guess the
most important thing
is remembering a script.
So you at least you know
what you're going to speak,
and then you probably just want
to focus on being yourself.
Because at the end of the day,
we don't want to be Bill Nye.
Still we want to be ourselves,
but we must be clear.
So you have to balance
those two objectives.
And this is just me just
talking off my head,
but I had no objective coming
into these reflections.
Yeah the question
was interesting,
because it was
just-- it was the day
after-- am I right to say it was
the day after the students came
in?
And if you saw my
first day picture
it was extremely embarrassing.
Thank God for not showing it.
ELIZABETH CHOE: It's not bad--
it's really not that bad.
JOSHUA: I was
explaining like hashing,
and it was like some security
concept that's so hazy that--
ELIZABETH CHOE: It's actually--
it was quite a good video.
Very clear and succinct.
I now know that my password
is safe on Facebook
just as long as I update
it every now and then.
JOSHUA: Yeah, but I've now
understood my audience.
And so the point of this
video-- and hopefully
what I wanted to show was
something very accessible,
something you use everyday.
And it goes deeper and deeper
until it goes to a concept
that you're not
very familiar with.
But because you started off
at the very familiar point,
it lead you there.
And so I guess that's the
exciting part of the K-12
videos.
ELIZABETH CHOE: Awesome.
That was a point Chris
[? Babel ?] brought up a lot,
was taking the familiar
and making it unfamiliar,
or taking the unfamiliar
and making it familiar.
And I think this video
that we're about to see
does a great job of
taking something that's
familiar to all of
us and showing sort
of the unfamiliar side of it.
Any other final thoughts
before we show it?
JOSHUA: Ugh.
Don't cringe, but I better
hide under the table.
ELIZABETH CHOE: No, no.
JOSHUA: OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hi.
Do you find it
particularly difficult
to find a specific
item in your house?
Let's say you're looking
for a pair of gloves,
but you just can't find it and
you spend your entire afternoon
looking for it.
Well, you've just
encountered the same problem
that companies like
Google or Microsoft
encounter every single day, and
that's the problem of search.
Just like your house,
which stores a thousand
different items, Google
stores 45 billion index pages
of information.
What if every page
was a sheet of paper,
and we stacked
them up real high?
We would create
a tower 600 times
taller than Mount Everest.
Well, how can
Google find a result
so quickly when I
find it so difficult
to find a pair of gloves.
Well, searching
on Google is kind
of like looking for a
person in a big school.
Let's say I'm looking for
James in a row of classrooms.
One of the easiest
method would be
to go to every classroom next
to you until you find James.
There is a better method
called binary search.
Now, let's say the students
were arranges from A
to Z, one in each classroom.
We would then go
to the middle room
first and see if James is
there, and if James isn't there
we would look at the
first letter in the name,
and if the letter is before
J, we head to the right.
If not, we head to the left.
We would then approach
the middle room
in the newly sectioned area.
Eventually, we will repeat the
process over and over again
until we find James.
Now, this is just the first
method, but it's at a much,
much faster rate.
How much faster will that be?
Well, that depends on the number
of students in the school.
Let's say there are 500 students
and we are looking for one.
It will take about 80
minutes in the first method,
but one and a half minutes
with binary search.
But let's say there are
1,000 students in the school.
It will take 160 minutes
with the first method,
but 1.6 minutes with
the second method.
Now, that's a whole
lot of difference.
So a name is just
a word, but Google
searches a combination of words,
making it a little bit more
complicated.
So just like how we
identified the first letter
of each alphabet
of the name, Google
identifies 200 unique factors
making the search terms faster.
Well, if you recall, the
effectiveness of binary search
depends on the
pre-arrangement of data,
and that's why computer
scientists are actively
looking for ways to sort,
manage, and eventually retrieve
data faster and better.
In the same way, the TV
remote goes near the TV,
the shoes go to the shoe rack,
the coats go into the cupboard,
and the winter gloves go
into the winter jacket.
Aha!
So that's where my gloves are.
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELIZABETH CHOE:
OK, so like I said,
given the incredibly
small amount of time
and the small amount
of resources they had,
I think that these videos
are pretty impressive.
It's pretty impressive
what they were all
able to achieve in such
a short amount of time.
We didn't even really
hit music, which
is like an entirely separate,
time consuming thing.
But well done everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
I wanted to thank all
the teaching staff who
made this class possible.
Sarah, you're an awesome TA.
Jamie, the co-instructor.
We had George [? Ziden ?]
come and teach hosting.
We had the guys from Planet
Nutshell, Josh and John,
come and teach script writing.
Chris [? Babel ?]
taught a lot of how
to make the camera techniques
advance your narrative,
so it was really a
collaborative effort
to make this class happen.
Just like hopefully
you guys realize
how much of a
collaborative effort
it takes to make a video.
So big thank you to everywhere
who made this class possible.
So all of these videos
and everyone's stuff
is up on our Tumblr if
you guys are interested.
I don't know when we're going
to offer this class again.
We'll see what happens.
But in the meantime, best
wishes to all the students
from Singapore who are
going back tomorrow,
and then the
remaining students--
I've talked to most of you
guys but waiting to hear back
from one person-- we'll
be producing their videos
for Science Out Loud
season three next week,
in addition to a few more
that we've been developing
in parallel to this class.
So maybe when the spring
semester rolls out
you'll not only be able to
see their progress from pitch,
to script, to second
script, to rough cut,
to final project, you'll also be
able to see their final product
in the videos that
we produce for them,
which is going to
be really exciting.
And that big thanks
to Opencourseware too,
for helping document this class.
It will be interesting to
see that roll out this summer
as well.
But feel free to take--
if there's food left,
feel free to take it.
There's plenty of salad
left, which is unsurprising.
But other than that, thanks
so much for coming out.
Feel free to-- I'm going
to volunteer the students,
if you want to ask them about
their experiences, you can.
But other than that,
have a great evening,
and thanks again, everyone.